[Music]
so you're the very powerful sugar
industry in America big sugar you sell a
commodity that Americans are addicted to
how addicted 152 pounds that's how much
sugar the average American eats every
single year for some contexts if you
weigh 150 pounds you would be eating
your body weight and sugar every year
that's six cups of sugar every week most
people can't imagine a world without
sugar almost everything we eat has some
sugar in it yogurt cheese bread and milk
fruit juice even ketchup all these foods
have sugar in them and the American food
industry relies on sugar and who can
blame them sugar is such an innocent
ingredients I mean it's the basic
ingredient in candy the happiest food in
the world and for decades that's about
as much as we knew about this magical
ingredients
people love sugar and the guys who
produce sugar well they make billions
until people started learning that sugar
is actually pretty toxic
the public started turning on the white
gold and suddenly sugar demand dropped
and companies started turning to
artificial sweeteners for the sugar
producers it was a nightmare their
bottom line was taking a massive blow
something had to be done sugar is a
commodity it sells for around the same
price all around the world but not if
American Big Sugar had anything to do
with it so a new plan was hatched an
unspoken agreement the big sugar
producers in America would band together
to make sure they still profited at the
expense of you the results today
Americans paid between double and triple
the price of sugar compared to anywhere
else in the world
this is America's ruthless sugar cartel
[Music]
now typically if you want to make more
money in business you have a few options
you can either make a better product
that can sell at a higher price or to
more people or you can improve the
marketing to again sell it at a higher
price or to more people but both of
those things take a lot of effort and in
the case of sugar it's a commodity
there's not much more to it than nuts
but what if I told you there was another
way that instead of working harder
providing a better service making a
better product marketing it better we
could just get the government to raise
our prices and protect our sales but why
would the government want to help dig
business well you have to frame it in a
way that helps these politicians stay in
power it has to benefit them too with
the public turning against sugar shelf
from the rooftops that our Farmers the
people that feed America are suffering
we need to protect their interests you
wouldn't want to come across as
anti-agriculture would you here let's
make this innocent sounding thing called
the U.S sugar program to to protect our
sugar farmers and what do you know in
2002 the first version of the U.S sugar
program was implemented little did the
public know that this U.S sugar program
wasn't protecting the interests of some
sweet farming family in California but
the interest of big sugar and the public
was about to pay the price
here was the pitch sugar demand is going
down we don't want to go out of business
so government give us a loan so we can
keep operating as normal and we'll pay
you back once we sell the sugar a fairly
reasonable Arrangement on the surface
the federal government would give loans
to the major sugar producers using the
sugar they make as collateral once the
sugar producers produce and sold their
sugar they would then pay these loans
back with interests it was the perfect
way to support American Agriculture and
now these billionaire sugar bears could
never be accused of getting handouts
from the governments after all they had
to pay it all backward interest rates
but here's where it gets good you see in
this new bill it was agreed upon that if
any sugar producers couldn't pay back
their loans they could default and
offered the government actual sugar to
make up for the lost money the
government could then take that sugar
and sell it to ethanol producers to make
their money back there was only one
issue if sugar prices fell too low the
government would be losing money on the
loans it gave out and if all the sugar
producers defaulted at the same time the
government would end up with tons of
sugar worth less than the loans they had
given to producers it would be a
financial nightmare we can't let that
happen so the government's solution
price fixing fix the price of sugar so
it never goes low that way both big
sugar and big government are in the
clear no risk if the price and demand
for sugar stayed high enough all the
sugar producers would be able to sell
their sugar and pay back their loans
with interest earning the federal
government a nice profit and making the
sugar bears richer than ever before this
is how the government did it first the
US Department of Agriculture put a limit
on hookah Farm Sugar In America which
conveniently prevents any new
competition from entering the industry
very cartel-like these threats went only
to a few of the country's biggest
producers then they restricted Imports
of sugar from other countries also very
cartel-like and then to make sure the
approved sugar producers make just
enough sugar to keep prices steady the
USDA controls how much sugar local
producers can make only enough to serve
the need never enough to cause a dip in
prices which sounds eerily similar to
the Soviet Union and if we end up with a
surplus of sugar while the government
will quickly buy it up sell it to
ethanol producers at a loss all to
prevent the price of sugar from dropping
too low and who makes up for the
government's losses taxpayers of course
you
the U.S sugar program costs American
taxpayers between two to four billion
dollars a year to maintain that's an
average of 125 dollars per household
every year 125 dollars being taken out
of your pocket by force every year and
into the pockets of bureaucrats and big
sugar and even more money is taken out
of your pocket for paying higher prices
for things containing sugar also the
American Big Sugar can charge 59 cents
per pound of sugar while the rest of the
world charges an average of 20 cents and
now it's time to meet the faces behind
this sugar cartel
[Music]
meet the sugar cartel these guys are at
the top of the sugar industry they're
the owners and CEOs of America's biggest
sugar producing companies they're also
some of the biggest Spenders on lobbying
in the crop industry in fact Big Sugar
spends millions of dollars every single
year on Republicans and Democrats to
make sure they keep the sugar program
going these are the fun whole Brothers
Jose and Alfonso were born into a rich
Cuban family who lost everything with
Fidel Castro took power their dad a
Cuban sugar producer fled to America and
quickly made a fortune re-establishing a
sugar business in Florida today the
Florida Crystal Corporation is worth
billions and the brothers Bloomberg
values the three oldest van holes and a
combined 8.2 billion dollars
coincidentally the van hole brothers are
one of the biggest contributors to Big
politicians campaigns and projects it
was their company along with all the
other big sugar producers that got
Harvest scientists to blame heart
disease a saturated fat instead of sugar
on one side those who claim it's a
harmless source of calories and quick
energy on the other those who say there
is evidence to implicate sugar not only
in obesity and tooth decay but also in
hyperactivity and diabetes among other
things
as you know there are reports citing
possible links between sugar and heart
disease diabetes obesity tooth decay
hypertension yes and Sugarloaf I know is
not responsible for any of these
diseases but certainly the risks
associated with a high consumption of
sugar are demonstrably large I'd have to
disagree the risks associated with the
high consumption of calories are
demonstrably large but not for the sugar
one of the first things that the public
relations campaign requested that the
sugar industry did was put together this
document called the sugar in the diet of
man
so they get stared organize it and stare
puts together a committee of researchers
who are very sympathetic to the idea
that fat and cholesterol are the
problems and then you know none of these
are sugar researchers then they print
out I think was 25 000 copies and they
distributed widely saying it's not sugar
it's fat
so the first document I found was
related to the release of this white
paper and it was preparing the different
PR spokesman in the sugar industry on
what reporters might ask related to the
white paper and they talked about the
way that the paper was funded being an
unrestricted Grant they along with the
sugar Association also ran a PR program
that eventually led to Sugar becoming a
healthy part of obese and diabetic
people's diets
sweetening these delicious foods isn't
the result of research done in the
laboratory these results come straight
from the field 100 pure natural sugar
the sweetener only nature could make and
they make sure to play both sides and
2016 presidential election the brothers
hosted fundraising events for both Trump
and Hillary Clinton sugar and lobbying
are deeply connected a former deputy
assistant secretary to the treasury
Department famously said that sugar
dollar for dollar is the most
influential commodity in the U.S
[Music]
sugar is already bad but it can also be
really bad for the environments you see
once sugarcane is harvested most farmers
in America use a practice called cane
burning to ready the fuse for harvesting
unfortunately for places like Florida's
Everglades the fact that there are just
so many sugarcane farms around means
cane burning can become a toxic practice
you see cane burning produces a lot of
smoke like seriously a lot this smoke
can be so bad for people living near
sugarcane Farms that most big sugar
producing countries have banned the
practice completely most countries
except America in the Everglades a lot
of local residents suffer serious
breathing problems sinus issues and
Asthma all because of the ash created by
burning sugarcane they call it black
snow in some cases this black snow can
even contain cancer-causing pollutants
but that hasn't stopped American sugar
producers from using cane burning to
keep costs down and avoid using
expensive labor
for over 25 years now many of Chicago's
neighborhood bakeries have trusted their
recipes to one brand of sugar but it's
new to your Grocer's shelf Crystal sugar
our recipes have been handed down for
Generations the ingredients have to be
the best like Crystal sugar We Trust its
consistent quality
through all this these big sugar
companies have kept the public blind to
their schemes using some pretty smart
propaganda
and an official at Quaker Oats said one
of the best uses of sugar you could
think of was getting children to eat
their cereal
broadcasters advertising agencies and
toy companies all banded together to
prevent the FTC from regulating
children's television
just like big tobacco big sugar does
everything in its power to make people
believe that everything about sugar is
great where we are in the sugar debate
is about where the tobacco debate was in
about 1960 and you know I you can look
at Classic cigarette ads where they're
saying you know doc more doctors smoke
camels or they're good for your T-Zone
your throat and so with the tobacco
documents and the sugar documents that
she found okay show is that they're all
using the same Playbook they run ass
telling people that came burning isn't
harmful at all that the air quality in
those regions is not even that bad but
they forget to mention that the one air
quality monitor in the Everglades has
been malfunctioning since 2013 and even
when the tests are conducted they
usually measure the 24 hour or yearly
average and completely ignore the facts
that cane burning happens in specific
hour-long time slots that cause a spike
of intense pollution and when people
want to sue these producers for the
health issues came burning causes well
surprise surprise you go back to step
one week can't let our Vital Farmers be
attacked like that we have to protect
our food security so boom both Democrats
and Republicans has the right to Farm
Act in 2021 you're going to vote against
Farmers Right to Farm what kind of an
evil person are you do you want people
to starve the app protects agricultural
producers Big Sugar from nuanced
lawsuits including ones that claim
people got sick from black snow and when
people ask about the sugar program and
what it costs Americans well they're not
getting bailouts or handouts American
farmers don't get government checks
instead producers get government loans
that are repaid with interest which
means it costs taxpayers nothing they're
getting loans that they're repaying with
interests the U.S sugar program creates
jobs and protects our food security you
see the outcome of offering handouts
versus loans is functionally the same
but the framing the way you package it
the way you package the cartel makes all
the difference and the best parts is
that I bet you've never heard of any of
this before Big Sugar created the
perfect cartel foreign
cartel probably one of my favorite
cartels that we've reviewed on this
channel if you enjoyed this video my
name is Jake and we make documentaries
just like this one every single week on
money power and crime so click that
subscribe button we just passed 1
million Subs so let's get up to two mil
and if you want more documentaries that
are too controversial to be posted
publicly click that join button below
and if you join and you don't think it's
worth it you can always email me and I
will personally refund you the money
follow me on Instagram at jtrend.io
please watch out for fake accounts I
will never message you asking for money
that's gonna wrap it up thank you so
much for watching stay dangerous out
there and I will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]